trois invités ce soir bernard henri lévy
comment être ou rester de gauche
christophe ono dit biot sur l'état de la
birmanie et henri guaino comment être le
conseiller de nicolas sarkozy
bernard henri lévy bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous sortez le 9 octobre
prochain un livre qui sape qui s'appelle
ce grand cadavre à la renverse alors
vous allez nous expliquer cette citation
pourquoi ce grand cadavre autant dire
tout de suite que le cadavre en question
c'est la gauche dont vous nous parler de
la gauche est dans ce livre il ya à la
fois une part de d'autobiographie
intellectuelle est aussi une histoire de
génération au fond mais avant toute
chose et avant d'entrer un petit peu
dans le vif du sujet et pour nous pour
savoir pourquoi la gauche est un cadavre
à vos yeux en tout cas aujourd'hui
ce livre est né de quelque chose tout à
fait fortuite un coup de fil de nicolas
sarkozy dans coup de fil de nicolas
sarkozy au départ et en même temps on
découvre à travers ce livre que vous
avez joué un rôle non négligeable dans
la campagne de ségolène royal
donc pourquoi ce coup de fil de sarkozy
vous fait-il vous lancer dans cette
aventure et comment vous vous retrouvez
au côté de ségolène royal pendant toute
la durée de la campagne présidentielle
pratiquement en tout cas les trois
derniers mois les mois décisif alors
d'abord un ce grand cadavre à la
renverse avant sarkozy royal ya sartre
si je peux me permettre c'est à dire que
c'est une citation de sartre dans la
préface à dan arabi à propos de la
gauche de son époque 1960 dont il disait
déjà qu'elle était un grand cadavre à la
renverse et j'ai le sentiment
aujourd'hui qu'on est dans la même
situation
mutatis mutandis une gauche moribonde en
voie de décomposition
alors c'est vrai que ce livre c'est un
fait il est né vraiment de cette
conversation avec celui qui n'était
encore que le futur président qui me
téléphonent un après midi de manière
tout à fait sympathique d'ailleurs et
cordial c'était le jour où où mon
camarade andré glucksmann avait publié
dans vos colonnes
un article appelant à voter sarkozy et
sarkozy ils m'appellent pour me dire
alors quand est ce que tu me rejoins et
tu ne peux pas ne pas me rejoindre cette
gauche française dont on dit qu'elle est
ta famille est dans un tel état de
dépression et de décomposition que je ne
peux pas imaginer que tu en sois encore
donc je rapporte cette conversation et
je rapporte que je termine cette
conversation avec deux sentiments aussi
forts l'un que l'autre et qui donne
vraiment le branle à ce livre
le premier sentiment la première
certitude mais que j'ai à la seconde
même c'est que malgré tout malgré la
sympathie que j'ai pour le personnage et
même un peu plus les sympathisants se
connaît depuis longtemps je ne voterai
pas sarkozy
pourquoi c'est la première partie du
livre c'est la première partie devrait
lui revenir
-la deuxième certitude que j'ai au même
moment c'est que quand il me dit que la
gauche française est dans un état
pitoyable et notamment sur les grandes
questions qui me tiennent à coeur
le darfour la tchétchénie les droits de
l'homme etc
gr il n'a pas complètement tort et ça
c'est la deuxième partie du livre
donc c'est vrai que cette conversation
elle a été séminal quoi inaugural c'est
bon et le 27 janvier en même temps elle
provoque chez vous une réflexion
salutaire parce qu'elle vous amène à
réfléchir au fond d'abord à d'où vient
la gauche il ya un petit peu ça dans
votre livre
quels ont été les les strates
successives qui font que quelqu'un comme
vous êtes engagé à gauche et quelle est
la pertinence de ses engagements
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il en reste qu
est ce qu il doit en rester et donc en
effet pourquoi est-ce que vous ne serez
pas partie de ceux qui parmi les
intellectuels et parmi vos amis et
rejoignent que la sarkozie au contraire
vous allez aux côtés de ségolène royal
mais aux côtés de ségolène royal jours
et vous nous en disiez aussi un mot
aussi parce que c'est aussi fortuit que
le coup de fil de sarkozy finalement
c'est encore plus surprenant parce que
vous venez de nous dire à l'instant que
vous connaissiez nicolas sarkozy depuis
longtemps vous connaissiez peut-être -
ségolène royal dont comment tout cela se
produit et puis surtout me semble-t-il
auprès de ségolène royal il ya déjà
quelqu'un c'est jean pierre chevènement
donc vous
et jean pierre chevènement embarqué s'il
faut cire sur le même bateau sur le même
navire
c'est quand même au delà de la surprise
parce qu on le vérifie enrôler en lisant
votre livre c'est une part de vos
ennemis enfin intellectuellement parlant
j'entends jean pierre chevènement et son
courant alors beaucoup de choses d'abord
ségolène royal je la connaissais pas je
ne l'avais je crois jamais rencontré
deux c'est totalement fortuit en effet
c'est une amie commune fred vargas je le
dis dans le livre qui organise une
rencontre où nous faisons connaissance
3 parce que je suis honnête et a pu un
peu romancier je vois tout de suite que
j'ai affaire à quelqu'un d'exceptionnel
au moment même où se fait tirer à boulet
rouge par ses petits camarades par le
bureau politique de son parti et c'est
moi j'ai le sentiment inverse qu'elle
est très bonne
charismatique ça va sans dire informer
et cultivé culture politique franchement
au moins égale à celle de la plupart de
ses camarades des réflexes ah c'est sûr
ça en deux occasions
bref elle me politiquement je suis je
suis très convaincu 3
chevènement oui à l'époque je ne s'est
pas améliorée à l'époque je ne le sais
pas je le découvre dans un article du
monde d'ailleurs d'ariane chemin puis
après j'ai des après j'ai des indices
ase et c'est vrai que je finis par
comprendre mais il est là avec sa petite
équipe il est là avec ses petites et il
est vraiment il pu appuyer sur un bouton
pour sortir un texte sur ceux ci intègre
sur cela et vous même vous êtes un petit
peu à vous tout seul dans la même
fonction
faut vraiment totalement informelle est
totalement inconnu du public de l'agent
vite vous dire en effet il m'est arrivé
de voir quelquefois ségolène royal
pendant cette période
le fait de savoir que chevènement était
dans les parages
j'ai envie de vous dire raison de plus
raison de plus parce qu'en effet je
connais chevènement depuis longtemps il
incarne pour moi ce qui est pire à
gauche
vous étiez croisé déjà au temps de
françois mitterrand ce mitterrand au
temps des experts c'est une très vieille
histoire autant du groupe d experts dont
j'étais membre dont il était peut-être
membres aussi je ne sais plus très bien
mais on sait qu'on s'est connus g
c'est chargé par françois mitterrand ça
remonte à il ya 35 ans vous allez oui
d'un sujet qui était censé être sa
spécialité qui est l autogestion et
mitterrand qui avait le nez creux et qui
savait surtout ce que c'était que la
droite et la gauche pour être lui-même
un mixte assez réussie des deux il
savait que chevènement c'était bizarre
que c'était à droite la droite dans la
gauche il savait ça et il me charge de
ce dossier là de l'autogestion à
l'époque j'étais marxiste léniniste pour
justement contrer et pour moi ce qu'un
quart de chevènement il s'est pas
qu'elles sont deux personnes le
souverainisme l'esprit national
républicain le patriotisme avant toute
chose la haine de l'europe l'idée qu'il
faut soutenir saddam hussein sous
prétexte qu'ils seraient libres je peux
vous faire la liste c'est pas la peine
il n'y a pas là pour répondre ni dans le
livre m'a fallu il y répondra peut-être
tout ça pour moi c'est ce que la gauche
véhicule aujourd'hui de pire à la gauche
quelques jeux l'entente libérale ouverte
européenne et social démocrate donc
quand je comprends en effet que
chevènement joue dans le dispositif une
plainte et un rôle important
ça pourrait me dissuader je pourrais me
dire dans ce cas je veux retourner à mes
chères études mais au contraire comme
j'ai l'esprit peut être un peu
batailleur je me dis raison raison plus
pur
raison plus voilà comme voilà le
résultat ségolène royal a perdu il ya
quand même une
passé le choc de l'élection passée la
ferveur qui a eu aussi autour d'elle il
ya quand même aujourd'hui de la part
d'un certain nombre de gens qui ont pu
voter pour elle un grand mouvement de
recul et puis toute cette affaire de
rénovation de la gauche et c'est donc on
va en dire deux mots pour vous nous
disiez peut-être comment vous la voyez
cette rénovation cette refondation les
mots sont les plus couramment utilisés
mais c'est sarkozy qui a gagné sarkozy a
gagné et il a gagné au fond en prenant
beaucoup de gens à contrepied parce que
tout le monde attendait fachos sarko
c'est pas tout à fait les fachos sarko
qui est arrivé c'est au contraire
l'ouverture premier acte nicolas sarkozy
politiques présents la clique c'est
l'ouverture dans l'ouverture il ya un
nouveau plus proches amis
intellectuellement parlant j'entends qui
est bernard kouchner
donc comment vous analysez aujourd'hui
votre propre attitude vis-à-vis de
nicolas sarkozy parce que le livre est
construite façon telle qu'on se dise
voilà voilà les bonnes raisons qu'il y a
de ne pas cheminer avec nicolas sarkozy
voilà les bonnes raisons qu'il ya de
rester à gauche à condition que la
gauche d'en venir aussi tout à l'heure
ne s'écarte pas de ce qu'elle doit être
ou devrait être à vos yeux en tout cas
d'abord sarko facho je suis jamais tombé
moi j'ai jamais dit ça et j'ai même
d'ailleurs pendant tout le temps de la
précampagne la campagne ferrailler
contre ce cliché ce lieu commun et cette
imbécillité premièrement deuxièmement il
y avait je pense en revanche que sarkozy
quoi qu'il donne comme signe pas rasé
par ailleurs est un vrai homme de droite
et j'en prends trois exemples la
colonisation
cette affaire deux arrêtes arrêtons la
repentance
la france a fait oeuvre de civilisation
pour moi ça c'est la vieille droite
française la question de mai 68
cette phrase est incroyable il nous
reste 48 heures pour liquider l'héritage
de mai 68 u 16 juin doute que cette
phrase glaçante me leur élevé alors est
ce qu'il le pensait ce que c'est sous
l'influencé de de monsieur henri guaino
voilà on va voir si elle sera un peu
tout à l'heure parce qu'il va vous
succédez à très bien donc voulu poser la
question et puis vif
cette phrase qui a été ces phrases qui
ont été peu relevée qui pour moi ont une
importance extrême où nicolas sarkozy
pendant la campagne dit en gros la
france n'a tout de même pas inventé la
solution finale ce qui est totalement
exact où elle dit la france n'a pas
commis de crimes contre l'humanité ce
qui est faux ce qui est folle à la
france de papon la fonction de la france
de papon la france qui arrêtent qui
déporte et qui met dans les trains elle
participe du crime contre l'humanité est
ce à dire ça pour moi c'était comme un
acte d'effacement du très beau discours
de chirac roumanie enfin on verra si
nicolas sarkozy sur ce point se situe
dans la continuité ou dans la rupture
davantage irak après tout siège au
gouvernement christine albanel qui n'est
pas pour rien dans le fameux in the jar
comme par ailleurs on voit aujourd'hui
toutes ces histoires aussi il faut bien
le dire les choses comme elles sont ces
histoires de tests adn ces
tripatouillages avec quand même quelque
chose là deux traits essentiels on
touche pas à la dncc préfet convoque
pour leur demander de faire du chiffre
c'est à dire de d'atteindre les
statistiques requises pour les
expulsions de clandestins
moi je suis d'accord que les clandestins
ils sont clandestins ils n'ont pas
vocation à rester sur le territoire
national mais on convoque pas des
préfets dans secret pour leur dire vous
n'a pas atteint le chiffre les hommes
même clandestins sont pas des
marchandises
c'est pas du bétail c'est pas des stocks
de viande humaine et parallèlement à sa
fin et ça c'est le président lui-même à
la télévision l'autre jour face à vos
confrères patrick poivre d'arvor et
arlette chabot pour les quotas
professionnels ce qui pose déjà un
problème et pour les quotas
géographiques c'est à dire ethnique
ça c'est pas possible alors mais
justement le mot quota nous donne une
transition assez facile avec la gauche
parce que quand
nicolas sarkozy a parlé des quotas
justement il a trouvé un soutien à
gauche il a trouvé notamment manuel
valls qui est toile montante du parti
socialiste valeur d'avenir probablement
maire d'evry donc pas un socialiste
gésir c'est pas la gauche caviar manuel
valls c'est un socialiste de terrain
dans des endroits qui sont plutôt des
endroits difficiles et on lui dit mais
il faut pas craindre la notion de quotas
donc on voit bien ça renvoie d'ailleurs
à tout le débat qui peut y avoir à
gauche aujourd'hui sur comment se
redéfinit tél comment va-t-elle se
redéfinir donc moi j'aimerais vous nous
disiez un mot là-dessus d'autant danse
dans le livre dans votre livre
il y a la crainte malgré tout de voir
ressurgir à gauche un logiciel qui ne
vous est pas inconnu puisque c'est le
logiciel au fond vous aviez dénoncé dans
l'idéologie française idéologie
française qui avait marqué les années 80
et qui consistait à débusquer au fond
dans toute la pensée française ce qui de
près ou de loin ressortait à au fond
même de l'idéologie de l'état de vichy
et donc donc c'était d'une charge assez
forte à ses lourdes qui avait provoqué
pas mal de polémiques mais une partie de
la gauche était d'ailleurs concerné et
voilà qu'aujourd'hui vous voilà vous
êtes à nouveau en alerte comme si ce
logiciel là en question pouvaient re
surgir à la faveur de la rénovation de
la gauche
est ce que c'est bien cela que vous
voyez c'est exactement ça là on vient
d'en prendre un exemple c'est pas dans
le livre c'est arrivé depuis cette
affaire de quotas géographiques donc
ethnique
on y est en plein c'est pas possible
c'est contraire à la constitution c'est
contraire aux logiciels pour le coup
républicain et démocratique de la france
toute la latitude d'une partie de la
gauche vis-à-vis du libéralisme
vis-à-vis de l'europe
à vis de l'amérique ça participe de sa
l'antiaméricanisme pas se raconter
d'histoires c'est en france un thème
d'extrême droite
c'est comme ça à l'origine oui mais
enfin depuis différents courants qui ont
nourri une lentille américain du congo
meddah oui mais dans la même mais ce
n'est sans changer sans quand on fait ça
vous savez mon maître althusser même
enseigne et cela c'est une règle
élémentaire de l'épistémologie quand on
importe un concept d'un champ conceptuel
vers un autre il faut le dire
et il faut dire qu'est ce qui se passe
dans le déplacement qu'est-ce qui change
pourquoi c'est pas la même chose
et pourquoi c'est même le contraire et
c'est la gauche a pas de travail c'est
aussi important que gbagbo devait nous
dire par exemple en quoi leur anti
américanisme diffère de celui des
fascistes des années 30 je connais pas
un texte de gauche ou d'extrême gauche
des vingt dernières années qui est fait
ce boulot et à linverse quand on fait
pas le boulot ça vous revient par des
airs comme les minimes diplo les
articles qu'on lit régulièrement sur la
tentacule américaine les synarchie new
yorkaise pas si gencives quelques-uns
bons sont pas tous de cette veine là on
n'est sûrement pas d'accord vous et moi
là dessus il plonge parfait enfin c'est
en tout cas c'est ma conviction
faute d'avoir fait ce travail de
critique
eh bien on est ré envahi par set vous
disiez la constitution c'est quoi la
constitution de la gauche aujourd'hui
elle ce dont la gauche ne doit pas se
séparer d'abord dans ces strates
successives et aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous dites vous dit
quelque part dans la fin d'ailleurs du
livre bon le ciel est vide
le ciel est vide bon donc il n'ya pas il
n'y a plus de neil d'espoir
transcendantale ni de grand soir à
attendre le ciel le ciel est vide il
reste le deuil deuil dont vous dites que
la gauche doit le faire c'est-à-dire
deuil sincères c'est à dire le chagrin
sans la nostalgie et ensuite ils vous
dites il faut l'action mais alors
l'action vous l'a fondée sur quoi vous
l'a fondée à partir de quoi qu'elle
quels sont pour vous les points de
repère qui font que ça vaut toujours le
coup de s'engager à gauche aujourd'hui
et de quoi sera fait cet engagement en
tout cas pour ce qui me concerne et je
crois qu'il y à un certain nombre de
gens dans ce pays qui qui qui peuvent se
retrouver dans ce que je vais dire là
pour moi être de gauche c'est être
fidèle
en même temps à quatre choses à 4
mémoire c'est c'est très ces ensembles
quatre fils le dreyfusisme
l'antifascisme l'anticolonialisme et
l'antitotalitarisme le problème c'est
les quatre à la fois quand y'en a un
sens l'autre par exemple si on est anti
coloniale et antitotalitaire mettons on
dit au darfour
laissons faire les soudanais parce que
sans ça on va tomber dans le
néocolonialisme on oublie
l'antitotalitarisme si on est
dreyfusards sans être anti fasciste ça
veut dire que n'importe quel in
n'importe quel homme seul même si c'est
le dernier des salopards ou même si
c'est le dernier des imprudents même si
c'est renaud camus mairie de la dre
défendu il faut le dreyfusisme avec
l'anti fascisme bref pour moi c'est ce
que j'essaie d'expliquer en tout cas
dans ce dans la nord dans ce livre il ya
quatre piliers qui appartiennent à notre
histoire à notre mémoire anti
colonialiste anti totalitarisme
dreyfusisme anti fasciste au fond il ne
faudrait pas qu'une feuille avec un
cadre il à terre avec chacune de ces
épis vérifier sur chaque éveil humains
en effet que l'on perd aucun défi sur
chaque événement ou sur chaque individu
vous choyer quelqu'un comme
mendès-france qui pour moi reste un
reste un modèle d'une extrême modernité
sur les quatre terrains
l'anticolonialisme il est parfait
l'antitotalitarisme jamais défaillant
l'antifascisme
fidèle à sa mémoire et à sa propre
action il dreyfusisme impeccable voilà
prenez françois mitterrand c'est moins
clair bon qui va là c'est moins clair
sur les moins claires mais c'est
politiquement plus réussite
mendès-france
oui mais qu'est ce que c'est que la
réussite en politique qu'est ce que
c'est que la réussite en politique on
vous aurait dit très clairement c'est
d'être élu c'est de gagner ça c'est
ensuite de gouverner oui eh ben je crois
qu'ils avaient tort moi je crois que
c'est gagné sur des bases claires en
faisant le travail intellectuel
nécessaire et ayant et en faisant une
politique honorable qui ressemble à
votre famille c'est pas gagner à tout
prix
certes et donc qu'elle le voit là mais
quand vous adressant aux ceux qui
prétendent aujourd'hui rénover la gauche
qu'est ce que vous leur dites parce que
dans la crainte que vous énoncez de voir
ressurgir un vieux logiciels qu'est ce
qui nourrit au fond cette crainte
jardinage leur dit par exemple il ya un
des chapitres du livre qui pour moi est
très important c'est le chapitre qui
concerne la question du libéralisme pour
moi l'une des lads est l'un des
scandales est l'une des énigmes de ce
temps c'est de voir comment le mot même
de libéraliser ostracisé par la gauche a
été mêlé mais abandonné ostracisé jeté
aux chiens fils naissent du libéria de
la gauche ne de la gauche de la gauche
c'est le libéralisme les premières lois
sociales du 18ème siècle la loi sur le
travail des enfants
c'est des lois qui d'inspiration
libérale le libéralisme n'a jamais été
comme nous le disent les
altermondialistes la loi de la jungle le
marché tout fuit sans le laisser faire
laisser passer tous les théoriciens du
libéralisme y compris les conservateurs
disent le contraire
le libéralisme n'est justement y compris
en angleterre pour essayer de mettre un
de mettre des ddd des règles et des
freins au pouvoir d'aider jurant de des
privilèges des cartels plus tard et
ainsi de suite
donc voilà un exemple récupérer ce qui
lui revient à la gauche dans cette
mémoire du libéralisme arrêter avec
cette folie qui consiste à aa a lâché à
brader tout cette part de la mémoire
ouvrière et de la mémoire socialiste
française un socialisme antilibérale
alors cela dit c'est une belle histoire
c'est pas maintenant
jules guesde au début du 20e siècle
gagne contre jaurès parce que c'est
comme ça qu'il s'est passé c'est ça qui
se joue en effet c'est le socialisme
libéral qui perd sa première bataille
contre un socialisme autoritaire
antilibérale et ça continue
jusqu'aujourd'hui voilà un cas un autre
cas la question de l'europe par exemple
à laquelle je pense à 06 h à pire mais
pour terminer d'un mot bernard henri
lévy est ce que pas simplement de façon
anecdotique est ce que vous continuerez
à vous reconnaître ou à placer vos
espoirs dans ségolène royal que vous
avez accompagné tout au long de la
campagne ouassou penser que bon les
choses vont vont se faire autrement
d'abord vous savez enfin je suis d'un je
suis d'un tempérament ça c'est
anecdotique mais c'est comme ça je suis
d'un tempérament fidèles donc je
soutiens les gens quand ils sont dans le
succès le triomphe possible je les
soutiens de la même manière quand il
semble à terre ou qu'ils sont un peu
plus esseulé donc déjà pour cette
raison-là jeu je me sens pas me
dissocier de ce que ségolène royal peut
avoir est par ailleurs
gg pour cette femme l'estiment que je
vous dis l'estiment intellectuelle et
politique que je vous dis et je continue
de croire aujourd'hui c'est pas
tellement mon affaire ni l'essentiel
d'ailleurs pour moi jeune homme d'idées
mais je continue de penser qu'elle est
aujourd'hui la mieux placée pour s pour
refonder ce parti socialiste bien sûr et
bernard henri lévy merci donc le 9
octobre
j'ai édité chez grasset ce grand cadavre
à la renverse qui est au fond une la
première pierre de quiconque voudrait ou
espérerait refonder une gauche moderne
merci merci et j'en arrive aux oreilles
christophe ono dit biot bonsoir vous
êtes grand reporter en reporter au point
et vous sortez un roman qui s'appelle
lihrmann aux éditions plon qui est un
roman d'aventurés au point de départ un
jeune secrétaire de rédaction secrétaire
d'un action dans un journal c'est celui
qui met en page dans les journaux
moderne maintenant ça s'appelle éditeurs
donc plus que de la mise en place mais
néanmoins c'est un rôle réputé modeste
et il rêve d' aventure part en vacances
en thaïlande rupture en thaïlande de la
thaïlande
il arrive en birmanie où là il rêve de
faire la grande interview du siècle
celui du pape du triangle d'or grande
production d'opium dans cette région etc
on va pas raconter votre livre on n'est
pas ni encore que ce soit en soi un
roman d'aventurés mais moi j'ai surtout
vu dans ce livre birmane un roman
d'amour un roman d'amour pour la
birmanie
pour un pays et pour un peuple et il se
trouve que ce peuple aujourd'hui dans un
espèce de télescopage assez fascinant a
surgi au devant de l'actualité
ea nous a rappelé qu' il était sous la
botte d'une dictature depuis une bonne
vingtaine d'années depuis plus longtemps
en fait mais cette dictature là ce
général là depuis dix neuf ans qu'il y
vit un prix nobel
madame suu kyi qui est une figure de la
résistance et de la liberté mondial mais
toujours emprisonnés enfin toujours en
résidence surveillée depuis depuis 12
ans et donc ce qui est intéressant dans
ce livre c'est cet amour que vous avez
pour ce pays pour ce peuple dans des
circonstances qui sont en effet
aujourd'hui dramatique
donc voila j'aimerais que vous me
fassiez partagé au fond ces sentiments
qui vous ont porté à écrire ce roman
non mais moi j'ai l'impression que l'on
découvre depuis une semaine un pays qui
pourtant figurait bien sur les cartes
même s'il avait changé
puisque la changer de nom récemment ça
encore décret décret du généralissime
c'est ça le généralissime than shwe dont
on parle de de plus en plus en ce moment
et moi c'est un pays que je connais
depuis depuis quoi depuis l'an 2000
c'est date de mon premier voyage ensuite
j'y suis retourné en reportage et
parfois c'est comme ça on est happé par
un pays c'est vrai que moi je suis
obsédée par là j'ai peur en fait que le
monde soit uniforme uniforme n'étant pas
un mauvais jeu de mot pour parler des
généraux et donc je cherche un peu les
lieux qui échappe à la marche du monde
et la birmanie était un de ces lieux
coincé entre entre la chine et l'inde
sous la botte comme vous l'avez très
bien dit d'une dictature et j'ai voulu
alors même qu'on le pape qu'on parlait
d'un boycott et qu'on demande aux
occidentaux de ne pas y aller moi je
trouve que en tant que journaliste en
tout cas et en tant que romancier aussi
il est nécessaire d'aller voir
simplement voir pour pour témoigner je
suis tombé oui amoureux de ce pays et il
était tellement tellement riche
tellement divers puisque on parle en ce
moment beaucoup de dictature mais il ya
de très belles images sur ce pays il ya
un peuple derrière y'a pas que ses
généraux il n'y a pas que la pauvreté ya
pas de la violence et une telle richesse
intel romanesque j'allais dire vous
parliez du triangle d'or que j'ai eu
envie oui dedans fermé ce qui n'est pas
non plus un jeu de mots puisque ans on
n'a plus envie que le pays se libère
mais de mettre tous pays qui me fascine
dans un roman et dans ce roman il ya
d'ailleurs une foule d'informations sur
la sueur sur la birmanie pays dans que
vous connaissez très bien et c'est ces
informations au fond que vous glissez au
travers de l'évolution de chacun de vos
personnages et donc la dictature aussi
est constamment présente dans ce livre
elle est présente d'abord d'entrée de
jeu par sous la figure d'un général qui
est le voisin de votre héros donc le
voilà le ton est donné tout de suite
c'est vrai que l'arrivée à rangoon
et bon la birmanie juste à côté de la
thaïlande et entre la thaïlande et et
rangoun s'est pas seulement une
frontière c'est un monde qui sépare ces
deux pays et dans l'avion je voulais
justement avec cette figure de deux
généraux ses généraux dont on parle
aujourd'hui je voulais montrer ce que
cet acte de passer dans un dans le
royaume de la peur effectivement il est
secrétaire de rédac de rédaction c'est
une petite main du journalisme il a
envie de vie ses rêves de partir dans un
pays seulement il est un amateur et la
birmanie n'est pas un pays pour amateurs
puisque c'est une dictature et je
voulais qu'on sente ce passage et quand
vous arrivez sur le tarmac de rangoon
sur la hausse sur l'aéroport où les
voyais orient goût d'aujourd'hui on good
voilà et anggun tout a changé serre
qu'il ya eu donc de birmanie spa s'est
remis à marc bon rangoon étant devenu
anggun oui avec les projets d'exfiltrer
la capitale aussi laisser faire par peur
justement de ce qui peut se passer dans
la capitale dont bombay est la capitale
à l'extérieur tout à fait là kerviel
savait life idiot ça veut dire la
demeure des rois et le généralissime
than shwe se prend pour un roi se prend
pour la réincarnation des grands rois
birmans donc comme tour ou à vermand il
veut avoir sa propre capitale et je
voulais qu'on sente à la fois cette
pression cette violence mais aussi aussi
la beauté de ce pays c'est que je pense
que maintenant que là que la birmanie et
est revenu dans l'actualité
j'ai peur vraiment personnellement j'ai
peur qu'elle ressorte aussi vite qu'elle
est qu'elle est revenue à nos mémoires
mais j'aimerais aussi apporté des images
de de la richesse et de la beauté de ce
pays sa formidable histoire et de cette
voie là de cette émotion de cette de
cette énergie de cette beauté violentes
qu'elles acquittent russell savez comme
moi que la loi médiatique est implacable
rires que quelque chose surgi dans
l'actualité et l ess couvert tout d'un
coup sûr couvert tout à fait puis
totalement découvert qu'elle c'est
dramatique c'est dramatique parce que la
junte à réprimer ce mouvement et que ça
serait dommage d'attendre vingt ans
encore et puis quelques quelques morts
en plus en gros en birmanie à peu près
autant de bronze qu'il n'ya de soldats
fait d'ailleurs probablement des mêmes
catégories sociales des issues de
catégories
généralement les plus pauvres et ce sont
ces deux communautés au fond qui forma
seul peuple qui sont face à face
aujourd'hui avec selon l'envoyé spécial
des nations unies aujourd'hui des
pagodes vide
donc on se dit où les ont-ils parquet
que vont ils faire comment comment les
choses vont-elles se passer c'est vrai
qu'à ses deux armées parce qu'on appelle
l'armée des bonbons l'appel l'alarmé
jaune
normalement non non pas qu à cause de
leurs de leurs vêtements
mais le jaune étant là une couleur
important dans le bouddhisme et c'est
vrai qu'il ya 400 mille moines à côté
quatre cent mille de l'autre à la seule
différence que l'armée vit en vase clos
une sorte de casse très mal payé
d'ailleurs pendant pour un futur en même
temps tout à fait pour l'amour de sûreté
demandée et alors que les bonzes les
moines et vous faites très bien de
parler des monastères qui sont vides
aujourd'hui les monastères c'est pas
comment comme en europe ils sont
vraiment inclus dans la ville à tel
point que chaque matin les moines quitte
les monastères pour aller demander
l'aumône mais c'est pas une aumône deux
pas de la mendicité mais chaque virement
quand il donne aux moines acquiert des
mérites qui allège son karma et donc on
a une armée est vraiment comment dire au
contact du peuple et qui s'est mise
d'ailleurs en fer de lance et on tampon
entre l'armée ce peuple et puis une
armée coupée du monde vivent de plus en
plus dans cette capitale
la nouvelle capitale du seigneur général
et qui dont on ne sait pas très bien
d'ailleurs comment elles peuvent réagir
puisque certains officiers auraient
quitté le pays pour ne pas avoir à tirer
sur les moines alors laissons le
romancier et revenons au grand reporter
vous avez dit dans un article récent
publié dans libération font un que vous
étiez assez peu favorable aux sanctions
parce que vous les croyez inefficace or
pourtant madame suu kyi en dessous qui
elle est plutôt pour les sanctions les
halles a donc elle réclame même des
sanctions
et puis la question qui hante tout le
monde sait voilà qu'est ce qui peut
advenir
parce qu'on sent bien que les militaires
ont repris la main ils ont pris la main
sans coup férir entre sont le pays est
quadrillée donc s'il va falloir attendre
20 ans ou bien est ce que une quelconque
chance de transition démocratique peut
exister selon vous alors là on rentre
dans la géopolitique effectivement de
sang soo qui réclame des sanctions elles
réclamaient même le boycott touristique
donc elle disait il ne faut pas aller
dans le pays moi quand je suis allé sur
place
j'ai rencontré les gens notamment des
jeunes notamment des gens de cette
génération emprisonné en 88 qui sont
sortis qui me disais bon c'est bien
gentil mais si personne ne vient dans le
pays
comme on n'a pas d'information et les
informations de quitte pas le pays
ce sera encore plus dur les virements
savent qu'ils sont qu'ils sont boycottés
et certains disaient voilà vous voulez
que déjà notre prix nobel de la paix
aung san suu kyi et bâillonné et
voudriez en plus nous bâillonner nous
parce qu'ils ont envie de parler alors
les sanctions économiques certains
birmans étaient contre dans la mesure où
le département d'état américain lui même
a établi qu'en 2003 il y avait déjà des
sanctions ça avait conduit dix mille
birmane à se prostituer pour survivre et
on sait aussi que les généraux la preuve
par les images du mariage de la fille du
général tenchu et qu'on avait couvert de
ruby de diamant les généraux ne se ne
subissent pas en fait le coût de ces
sanctions
alors là l'onu a parlé de sanctions
créative qui viserait à frapper
directement les généraux savoir si on
peut les frapper ou non exactement mais
ils ont des intérêts dans certaines
sociétés mais on fera pas tomber la
junte avec des sanctions militaires
alors comment pour répondre à votre
deuxième question faire tomber la junte
la junte ne tombera pas il faut profiter
dans le sens où qui pour et essayer de
l'infléchir la junte données de les
contraindre à négocier avec en dessous
qui depuis des années
c'est vrai qu'on ne parle jamais de la
birmanie donc tout ça on ne le sait pas
mais depuis des années la junte a établi
une feuille de route vers la démocratie
c'est une sorte de me de marché de dupes
imposée par de menus mais il ya eu déjà
des pourparlers en 2005 le premier le
premier ministre chef des services
secrets birman qui nyunt était négocié
avec aung san suu kyi il a été débarqué
limogé par l'actuel chef de la junte
donc pour moi les sanctions croire en un
effort en en une efficacité des
sanctions c'est un peu de l'illusion
croire que la junte tombera c'est aussi
une illusion
donc il faut que la commune et la
communauté internationale actionne le
levier chinois pour permettre à la à la
junte donné que de négocier avec en 5
suu kyi et son parti et les partis
ethniques parce qu'on n'a pas parlé de
ça non plus et dehors de remettre en
forme
cette feuille de route vers la
démocratie ça prendra peut-être du temps
ça sera pas génial tout de suite mais
c'est le seul levier la junte
en même temps je suis pas devin je
consulte pas l'astrologue comme les
clairement
mais la junte ne tombera pas mais ça
bien merci en tout cas christophe ono
dit biot votre roman s'appelle birmane
s'était dit et chez plon et ça donne
vraiment à vivre la réalité de ce peuple
j'avais pas prévu gamin voilà merci
merci à vous aussi
bonsoir henri guaino merci de nous
rejoindre ça vous êtes conseiller
spécial de nicolas sarkozy et chose tout
à fait inhabituel les conseillers du
président s'exprime prennent la parole
donc on en profite et donc je vous
remercie beaucoup d'être notre invité ce
soir vous avez été commissaire au plan
dans une vie pas si anciennes
antérieures
vous étiez aussi proche de philippe
séguin
donc question rituelle comment on passe
de ses gains à sarko et est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous seriez de ce qu'ils
recommanderaient à nicolas sarkozy de
réhabiliter l'outil planification si
toutefois ce beau encore un sens
aujourd'hui
alors comment on passe de ses gains donc
sarkozy assez assez naturellement
finalement d'abord exagéré divergences
non piotta toujours appartenu à la même
famille politique
fini par l'oublier c'est vrai et voilà
on finit par l'oublier mais tout de même
plus je pense qu'il ya plus de choses
qui réunissent les héritiers putatifs du
gaullisme que de choses qui les sépare
et puis moi j'ai trouvé c'est ce que la
sarkozie quelque chose qui nous tient à
coeur c'est la volonté de réhabiliter la
politique et cette idée que la politique
peut changer les choses peu influent sur
leur histoire
voilà je crois qu'on a beaucoup dit que
c'était un libéral
sans doute c'est quelqu'un qui croit
mais qui n'y croient pas d'économie de
marché au capitalisme mais c'est
quelqu'un qui ne croient pas aux laisser
dire rtt aux libertés évidemment
gallizia bérubé aujourd'hui quand on en
mai quand on parle du libéralisme on a
tendance à réduire sa au chant au champ
économique sur la liberté soit pire
jamais eu une divergence en france que
monde où à peu près tous les partis
aujourd'hui même sur une histoire
compliquée croit la liberté politique et
aux libertés individuelles aux droits de
l'homme
si un débat c'est sur le champ de
l'économie et moi je skie m'attacher cdu
que la sarkozie c'est ce refus du
laisser faire cette idée que le problème
se présente on peut pas rester les bras
croisés et attendre que les choses se
s'arrange naturellement et spontanément
voix c'est la réhabilitation de la
politique de ce point de vue pour moi il
ya une grande continuité dans ce que
j'ai fait écrit penser alors entre
laisser faire la planification va y
revenir mais auparavant moi je voudrais
vous saisir de ce constat que j'ai fait
dans en lisant le petit livre de yasmina
reza se consacrer à la campagne de
nicolas sarkozy
le personnage principal en dehors de
nicolas sarkozy bien sûr mais le
personnage principal de ce petit livre
récite campagne c'est vous même c'était
excessivement moi j'ai été assez frappé
de voir à quel point quel rôle vous avez
tenu pendant la campagne parce qu'il
s'agit pas seulement d'écrire pour
nicolas sarkozy mais il s'agit en même
temps de match et avec lui constamment
donc sur chaque événement et sur chaque
discours de vraiment d'être là au coeur
de la fabrication de ce qu'il va dire
donc de ce qui va l'engager après parce
qu'en plus il est élu donc tout ce qui
est tout ce qu'il a pu dire va l'engager
et vous êtes au coeur de cette de cette
machine l'a donc comment s d'abord quel
rôle
conservez-vous auprès de lui est ce que
toute cette proximité dans la dans la
gestation la conduite d'une campagne
vous hareng parti shas paix maintenant
que vous êtes forcément les choses sont
différentes la structure de l'état est
là et c est donc comment s comment est
votre lien aujourd'hui avec lui et que
quel regard jetez vous justement sur
cette période
de la campagne s'agissant de la campagne
sait par quelle était l'importance de
mon rôle mais mais en tout cas il est
vrai que pour moi c'était un engagement
politique moi je suis pas j'ai pas
vocation à être simplement être un
qui écrit voilà j'ai pas la profession
ne se fait pas profession d'écrivain
d'écrivain public même si je crois à
l'importance des mots moi c'était un
engagement politique l'engagement moi un
engagement d'amitié aussi donc je les
mener jusqu'au bout enfin je suis
jusqu'au bout cet engagement on a décidé
d'emblée de le faire d'ailleurs
publiquement rien n'a été caché
la participation à la campagne rôle que
j'ai pu j'ai pu y jouer
l'histoire dira après si ça a été
important ou tout à fait négligeable
or depuis que l'âme que des élections
ont eu lieu et que cela sarkozy est
devenu président de la république est ce
que les choses ont changé elles ont
fatalement changé
ça lui a changé j'ai sans doute forgé
aussi et puis le contexte a changé parce
qu'on porte à de la même manière en
campagne pendant une campagne
présidentielle et dans l'exercice du
dans l'exercice du pouvoir
est-ce que la proximité reste eh oui à
proximité et un c'est très grande je
vois là jeu mettait l'accent sur ce rôle
là parce que d'abord oria il ya un
discours fameux discours d'agen qui
porte votre empreinte et d'acier
vraiment beaucoup dit que c'était moi en
fait c'est lui qui a voulu paraître
drôle c'est sur leurs os et le foie
beaucoup de choses dans les secours
d'agen sur le à la fois la défense du
capitalisme et sa critique
il y avait la moralisation du
capitalisme financier il y avait la
question de l'euro il y avait beaucoup
de choses avec la valorisation du
travail mais c'est lui qui a souhaité
aborder c'est tout tous ces sujets c'est
si on a pu travailler ensemble de façon
aussi si proche c'est aussi parce que il
y avait une volonté commune d'aller sur
certains terrains d'aborder certains
sujets il y avait quand même beaucoup de
choses en commun au départ mais
justement à partir de ce rôle moi la
question qui m'intéresse chez vous c'est
comment donc quelle définition vous
donneriez du sarkozysme quelques à
l'espoir avez-vous que sera le
sarkozysme si on devait aujourd'hui
définir parce qu'il ya déjà eu un
premier contrepied au départ il ya eu
l'ouverture
donc c'était s'était déjà l'ouverture
d'un autre tour à moi de limiter
l'ouverture à au débauchage ce qui ne
semble pas et grands la volonté
présidentielle
donc voilà du coup la définition du
sarkozysme dans votre dans votre esprit
c c'est court ça devrait être prend
d'abord la l'ouverture n'était n'a été
une surprise que pour ceux qui ont fait
campagne contre un candidat nicolas
sarkozy imaginaire qui d'ailleurs l'ont
perdu j'ai été frappé de voir à quel
point
tous ses adversaires faisait campagne
contre notre candidat que le candidat
réel ils ont imaginé un candidat et
c'est celui-là qu'il voulait combattre
ça n'avait rien à voir avec le candidat
réel ni avec ce qu'il ressentait il ya
ceux qui me disait ni avec ce qu'il
faisait l'ouverture elle a été présente
dans toute la campagne on l'a même
reprocher d'en avoir parlé trop tôt je
pense à un discours à la mutualité et
dans beaucoup de discours il y avait des
passages sur l'ouverture d'esprit sur la
nécessité de s'ouvrir aux autres à ceux
qui ne pensent pas de la même manière
ceux qui ont une autre expérience
deuxièmement ça correspond à une vision
que moi j'approuve depuis longtemps qui
est celle d'un président qui est le
président non pas de la majorité qui l'a
élu mais de tous les français puisqu'il
va incarner son pays va parler au nom de
tous les citoyens de ce pays
donc ça les oblige à aller au delà des
clivages traditionnels ce général de
gaulle disait la france ça n'est pas la
gauche la france n'est pas la droite
c'est tous les français voilà il est le
président de tous les français donc moi
je donc c'est pas un contre-pied cetc
poussé la logique de nos institutions
car caractère au dessus des du régime
des partis
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à lui à leur ultime
une interprétation et ce point de vue il
n'ya pas de dire pour moi il ya pas
tellement de surprises en tout cas c'est
dans la logique de la la campagne de la
campagne remercier il faut maintenant il
faut un peu tout faire en même temps il
faut au préalable il faut un que sais
qu'il faut que le faire en même temps si
on veut être fidèle à ce que l esprit de
cette campagne
après tout on m'a demandé de m'a demandé
de venir à netease et pour ça pour
essayer de faire en sorte que continue
ce qu'on avait commencé qu'on s'inscrit
dans le droit fil de cette campagne a du
temple où je déteste cette expression
parce qu'il n'ya pas de temples vous
demandé ce qu'était le sarkozysme mais
ce n'est pas une doctrine c'est pas une
idéologie c'est une façon de gouverner
vous savez même même degré de récuser le
gaullisme c'est une idéologie ou une
doctrine
donc il n'ya pas de sarkozysme et il ya
un rapport de nicolas sarkozy au pouvoir
à la politique
une façon d'être en politique et puis il
ya la volonté je crois d'être fidèle
tout ce qui a été dit pendant la
campagne on à dire souvent dit je ne
vous tromperez pas je ne vous mentirai
pas voilà maintenant il s'agit de tenir
cette parole qui dans le passé n'a pas
toujours été tenus par tous ceux qui ont
été élus alors une question je m'en
voudrais de ne pas vous poser puisque je
vous tiens à votre place à l'instant il
y avait bernard henri lévy qui lui a été
marquée à l'envers par phrase d'un
disnat des discours de nicolas sarkozy
sur il faut liquider il est temps je
crois de liquider l'héritage de mai 68
ça ça on vous la tribu alors pour le
coup est un fait politique et y est allé
dire liquider l'héritage de mai 68 quel
sens peut avoir dans la société
d'aujourd'hui quand on se souvient à
quel point la société d'avant 68 et tout
fait et un canon points 68 a pu être
aussi une pulsion libéral peut-être un
peu trop libertaire à vos yeux mais dont
fondements étaient quand même parfois
libertaire d'abord je crois qu'il faut a
été aussi de caricaturer la société
d'avant 68
nous sommes en république nous étions en
démocratie voilà personne n'était dans
un régime de dictature étouffant et la
question des moeurs qui cda morale qui
s'est posée en mai 68 a été posée dans
tous les pays du monde et elle était
l'aboutissement d'une longue
fermentation et d'une longue évolution
tous les pays n'ont pas connu exactement
le mai 68 français pourtant ils ont tous
est le même le même chemin donc pour pas
surestimer non plus la valeur de cet
événement ou de cette de cette révolte
qui a été en grande partie d'ailleurs
une ronde l'enfant gâté il faut aussi
demain il faut aussi le dire
alors ça laissait simplement des traces
dans la société française je crois que
d'une chose très positive parce qu'il
faut les imputer directement à mes sens
du bit la libération de la femme le
l'avortement etc mais qui n'avons
remarqué d'ailleurs ça n'a pas été
la liberté d'avorter en france n'a pas
été n'a pas été votée décidé par des
gens qui étaient sur les barricades en
1068 voilà c'est madame simone veil
monsieur giscard d'estaing monsieur
chirac donc il faut rendre à césar ce
titre ce qui revient à césar le ya eu
des aspects en revanche des conséquences
relativement négative je pense à tout ce
qui a trait à l'autorité contestation
radicale de l'autorité à la contestation
radicale aussi de la transmission et
qu'on est allé beaucoup trop loin dans
cette de ce côté-là ça en grande partie
ruinée les fondements de notre modèle
éducatif sans qu'on le remplace par rien
de viable cette idée de cette idée que
il faut - transmettent il faut moins
posé à l'enfant de règles de contrainte
que l'enfant est au coeur du système qui
désacralise et dans le système éducatif
a eu des résultats tout à fait
désastreux
on peut penser le contraire je tenterais
bien qu'ils aient entre les pédagogistes
d'un côté les traditionalistes de
l'autre des affrontements sans fin
l'idée qu'il faut liquider à la fois cet
héritage excessif des crises de qui a
débouché sur la crise de l'autorité puis
cet affrontement stérile a essayé de
faire dans sa lettre aux éducateurs
essayer d aller au delà de passer par
dessus
tous ces débats qui maintenant n'ont
plus lieu d'être qui datent de de 40 ans
l'a donc voilà une idée c'est ça c'est
peut-être cette essayer d'être moderne
sans mai 68
henri guaino juste avant nous quitter un
mot il ya une frustration chez vous
d'être conseiller spécial et d'être pas
je sais pas en charge d'un ministère ou
de quelque chose qui vous donne une
presse plus concrète sur le jeu parce
que ma prise et très concrète sauf que
je ne décide de rien mais au fond qui
décida par le président de la république
c'est très très peu de gens ont fait en
vrai pouvoir de décision donc moi je
j'étais par candidat spécialement être
post conseiller spécial à l'elysée je
suis allé là où le président a jugé que
je serai utile ou moi je n'aspirais qu'à
servir mon pays ça paraît très ringard
être des raisons enfin c'est comme ça
voilà alors ça ne veut pas dire que dans
ma vie je n'aspire pas un jour avoir le
résultat ferme travail dans lequel je
vois le résultat des décisions que je
prends
est ce que c'est en étant ministre je
n'en suis pas absolument sûr l'avenir le
dira mais reconnaît en mairie et non
merci